yeah the only anime i've been watching
recently which i highly recommend
is a odd taxi that's that's yeah i've
been meaning to watch
actually something that's just gone
under the radar
and it is probably like i think maybe my
anime of the season i don't know it's
it's tough
like i mean it really it really was a
sleeper hit i i can tell you what's not
enemy of the season [ __ ] one droid
priority overview yeah i know
so so we'll we'll get on to that but
yeah um
so like okay so from odd taxi i don't
know anything but i've also been told
that
you don't want to know anything because
yeah from whatever everyone's told me
and that's probably why it's having a
hard time getting
promoted if you tell people what it's
about it sounds like one of those shows
that kind of gets ruined a bit when or
spoiled if you tell them even anything
about kind of it's it's
more so if like it's kind of hard to
tell you what it is about
because it's about i assume it's about
taxis
kind of like the biggest thing the
reason is called
odd taxi is because the main character
is a taxi driver okay i guess but i
i guess like the hardest the easiest way
to describe it is kind of like a
tarantino movie or something
something along those lines is it like
taxi driver
you said that to me and i was like i'm
pretty sure i know what's going to
happen in this thing just off that
description
where i'm like oh i bet there's going to
be like a bunch of people who come in
the taxi and they seem all unrelated and
then we find out that everything is all
related and tied together in a neat
story i bet that's what it was yeah
that's that's exactly what it's like
tarantino but i mean i mean that's the e
that's like the easiest way you can
describe it because it is
it is kind of like a current uh a
tarantino movie and what i love about
odd taxi is that
it's been so long since i've just seen
an anime
that has just set up set up his premise
told its story and then just wrapped
everything up in a neat little package
and the part of the reason i think it
like blew up a lot in like the past week
it's just because
it's ending was just really [ __ ] good
it tied everything up and this
is finished now yeah it's finished now
how many episodes it's uh 13 episodes
and you just
you watch this anime and it's 13
episodes and that's it there's no more
everything's tied up it's a really
really good
ending now how do we milk it for more if
it's just god how do we merge it
i don't know i don't know about these
things i don't know you gotta love an
anime that has a clean ending
yeah it's just it's just clean it's just
like clean anime all right it's been
so long since i've seen an anime that
has just that's just got a really tight
script where it sets up everything you
need to set up
um it gives you the right yeah exactly
exactly just like a race yeah you just
like it it gives you the right climax
for everything that i set up and then it
just ends and i'm just like
dad damn that's just everything i need
in the show that's what i love
about watching tv shows and
it's been so long since i've seen a tv
show i'm gonna watch boys on taxi
i was about
and apparently i didn't watch one direct
priority but i heard it was a mess
i watched up to episode 10 i think so
yeah i'm only
you should probably just i don't know
where you're at i loved what i saw yeah
you should probably stop where you're at
okay so what the [ __ ] happened
basically uh well for stu i don't want
to give too much away but basically
half of the ova is a [ __ ] recap which
already was like a red flag to me i was
like
we don't we don't need a recap we don't
do that here we don't do that here we
just need a recap in an ending
you asked me man you [ __ ] asked me in
a 20 minute episode
i think it was 40 45 something like that
okay so it was so it was a true episode
about about 15 minutes of it was a recap
it was a really [ __ ] long record at
least it felt like a long time to write
when they get too comfortable with recap
and [ __ ] you know something's going
wrong
and then get a little too comfortable
with those recaps
and then they just added like three new
elements to the story
that just was introduced but never
resolved so we're like wait wait so you
literally just added this element
like 20 minutes before the ending and
then that's it
you know when people like love a show so
much they don't admit that it's wrong i
but there's people on twitter
i bet those people on twitter that were
like now now guys hold on they might
they might be onto something here yeah
yeah
please please do something fix what
you've done
please and it was just like uh and it
just felt so [ __ ] because like
again like the first season when i
watched when i watched it
it was [ __ ] amazing right like you
watched up until episode 10. yeah it's
[ __ ] amazing right
i couldn't wait for it to be concluded
yeah and
uh unfortunately it wasn't even
concluded with the final episode it just
left
more questions than answers and we were
just like cool so wait
wait when when when they didn't include
it did they leave room for a season two
or was that just uh
well [ __ ] you guys uh this is how it
ends i think what they i think they
tried to do like a really like
open-ended like madoka-esque ending
except
unlike the manuka ending nothing was
explained so like you couldn't even form
theories about what was anything right
like at least the model
ending it was kind of like all right we
can kind of figure out what life
leaves yeah it's like it's like we can
kind of figure out
why it ended like this right it's a lot
of us like very like
you know metaphorical and everything
it's like okay we can kind of figure out
theories of what this might mean
but with wonder they kind of did that
but they were like no clues for you
figure it out are you like oh you like
the show [ __ ] you
yeah [ __ ] you they literally it
literally was just like it it felt like
cloverworks was just like
all right i give up didn't roll the
credits